if you're on this side of the room in
the kind of front half of it what would
you like a rap about
the taliban okay wow great straight up
yeah can you put the lights on to check
he's not got a long black beard
great taliban i think it's taliban's a
more acceptable thing to shout out in a
venue i had a couple of people a few
years ago who would shout isis and
you're like [ __ ] run
the taliban what about what about the
taliban in particular
yeah
you're an ex-soldier so wait have you
served over there
holy [ __ ] i'm it's gonna get dark if i
carry on asking him questions so
okay cool cool so taliban lovely uh guys
over here kind of front on this side
what you want to wrap about
the solar system pick an aspect of the
solar system that isn't a planet
the the
mate that's a five-star review smashed
it mate yeah that's just what you were
about to say
the possibility of life enceladus
enceladus so that is presumably a moon
that's all right does anyone else no one
else [ __ ] knows
oh yeah
i'll find out on sun
yeah no that's good on sunday i'm
staying with my friend who's an
astrophysicist so
it's a nice planet there's gas plumes
has never been said
okay the solar system and the
possibility of life on enceladus great
uh which we don't know where it is but
it is a moon somewhere um the taliban
let's come to the back of that side uh
what would you like a wrap about
oh yeah no no let's add to the taliban
one yeah
the clip of them on the dodgems yes
just to lighten the mood so the
taliban's on dodgers great
because that was the one that like
someone tweeted that at like thorpe park
or something and they replied to it
being like we're so glad people are
having fun or something that's great
great talent the dodgers well we're
still on this side for a suggestion
what
goose fare dodges oh cool thank thank
you for giving me some local color
can we just check you don't have any
[ __ ] fighting mujahedeen as well
right that's
the most
you just like dodgems good out of the
two that's the one to choose isn't it
you know i like bumping into other
people not i will lay down my life for
the one true lord allah peace be upon
him his messenger and prophet muhammad
right um so
we're still on two suggestions and the
show is almost running over so what do
you want a wrap out over here
mushroom rim knob
yeah let me just ask
what you did say because that's
definitely not what you said mushroom
what
oh it is what
okay so i know what the word that sounds
like what you said is but i don't think
that is what you said what is
a mushroom rim knob oh it's because you
were saying mushroom rim knob not
mushroom rim knob
yes
emphasis is important right
you got to emphasize your words properly
a mushroom rim knob
[ __ ] nottingham what's with you
okay lovely people on this side let's
get our fourth suggestion yes hand up is
that a hand up yeah
rip the [ __ ] out of snowflakes okay
okay snowflakes like get it on i'm not
sure you've come to the right show um
i mean yeah it's a great suggestion uh
let me just tell you the penultimate
song of this is a hip-hop song without
any misogyny whatsoever and it seems
i've misjudged my audience completely
okay i'll uh okay so snowflakes and one
final suggestion doesn't come from
anywhere
donkey jacket yes not donkey comma
jacket um what is a donkey jacket is it
some type of hair shirt
a big black coat that dustbin men used
to wear um what do we call them bing
bing collectors i guess dustbin managed
to wear that was fashionable in the 80s
a donkey jacket is it like a kind of neo
in the matrix thing
that person said yeah that person said
no deciding vote no
that's a trench coat so what's the
difference between a donkey jacket and
trench coat
it's shorter
more donkeys
i don't know if you're a historian of
world war one there were quite a few
donkeys in the trenches but uh that
wasn't a good joke at all but still
[Music]
okay cool so
the taliban on the dodgems a donkey
jacket mushroom rim knob snowflakes rip
the [ __ ] out of them and the possibility
of life on n n what's it called
and
and
enceladus yes great um okay which beat
of these is going to be good for that
one okay let me just try it okay no
i've got four beats and they're
different moves
okay this actually yeah i think we've
got it straight away
[Music]
cool i'm very excited for this
so many clips online and i urge you to
watch them big black beard and they ride
in the dodgems not there down goose fair
but in kabul the taliban they spin right
round going one lock to the next bumping
from the back whiplash in the neck cause
they don't respect the war they'd be
winning all the men there but you know
no women not in the cabinet not at the
fun fair i saw a taliban man better run
clear you don't want it with his long
hair he's gonna get you out in
calcutta what's a [ __ ] place called
kandahar that's what i need trying to
think of other provinces you can't
succeed 20 years over there i don't
understand but i'm withdrawing no
dodgers on the sand gotta have a nice
flat linoleum floor it's the main thing
that they were fighting the war for you
like your taliban when you went to the
royal palace did you want the parliament
they're just like no we just want to
have a drive on all of the dodgers me oh
my ever so fun electric on the top and
why is this russian accent so we stop
right that i'm going over there
understanding look at me the
astrophysician i'm checking out the
planets of patrick moore this guy at
night say it right my telescope focusing
and i spy with my little eye what are we
chatting we don't even know which planet
is jupiter or saturn jupiter's got a lot
of moons it's kind of hot but the
gaseous plumes are not the big red spot
that's a storm but maybe it'd be saturn
with the rings start to seeing all the
solar system things you can't resist
thinking about the possibility of life
over there yes my advice would depend a
little probe little satellite takes a
while to get there maybe 10 years if i'm
right but probably some more it's much
farther than the asteroid belt by mars
there and let me serve this up i really
hope i'm envisioning correctly a donkey
ko not the little skin off an ass or a
skin of a mule the skin of a donkey
outside the school all the bin men are
up in the 8 a.m in the 80s popular with
dustin men they just be rocking off no
hive is they've got a fashionable
clothes they like this walking around
maybe it's waterproof you need it for
all the muck that be refusing from the
recycling didn't have that 30 years ago
technically it's 40. jesus christ i'm
trying to go bonkers with my head
snowflakes yeah [ __ ] wish they were
dead i'm not saying this guy doesn't
like the winter whether he's like all
the [ __ ] kids better pull himself
together back in my day we said rude
words but now they be like oh it hurt us
we don't like it we feel so sad oh i'm
so depressed my life is so bad but the
fact is depression was undiagnosed in
the past bin men wore the black clothes
because they thought people didn't give
a toss that's a pun bin men black
clothes look like goss and then we move
on got people online sending all this
abuse you like i don't mind but let me
say this they're not prudes i'm just
saying it's easy europe white dude like
me all the privilege and all the other
kids they ain't got a need they're
getting upset they wish they did have
something that would deal with the job
the solution that i've got that's a
mushroom rim knob i'm going there out to
wix i'm like so many handles for me to
pick i'm walking around here i don't
like this angle and this one too small
for the handle i need one with a wide
circumference a guy walks up and says we
should become friends i say what's your
name he says jim let me give you a
little knob with the rim and i'm like
whoa
i can't assume i consume him quickly but
there's not mushroom and so you know off
we prove we running over there get the
little kitchen lube what the heck does
that mean i'm bugger dana lee i'm
picking out the rob and it's such a
shame to see but i managed to ease him
in i start with this it's called pegging
there you go snowflakes for the kids
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]